[Musique]
enfin les enfants pourront soir
voyons nounours ne fait pas cette tête
je suis triste pas trop je n'aime pas
être séparé de mes petits amis je vais
m'ennuyer pendant ses vacances mais non
tu te recoudre à et nous irons voir
d'autres petits enfants dans d'autres
pays pour l'heure six patrons je descend
vite dire au revoir à nicolas et
pimprenelle mon échelle europe propos
pom pom pom pom pom pom
alors au flop et pas ratifié
bonsoir le petit tu sais c'est terrible
les départs on oublie toujours quelque
chose mon masque de pêcheurs vous
n'allez plus pouvoir la fermer cette
venue j'allais oublier mon réveil
et voilà que le groupe ne sont donc
attaqués pas airs avec toute la maison
n'oublie pas les raquettes pas prenait
les voilà on va jouer avec copie champ
vous forgez bien d'aller vous coucher
les petits demain vous devrez vous lever
de bonne heure et hussein à nourrir on
va prendre les traits le tri
vous en avez de la chance
en voiture
moi aussi j'aimerais voyager en train
toujours se
noierait tiens c'est pour toi un gros
coeur pour que de notre patte coccinelle
à kano dessus mon rêve
[Musique]
ce qu'il est chic
merci les enfants vous m'avez trop
gratter tu viendras nous faire en
vacances à c'est promis c'est promis
bonne nuit me petit temps
brassée de paix vacances
la jettent à la lumière
a
kyoto
bonne nuit mais nous sommes bientôt à
bientôt
[Musique]
à bientôt les enfants passer de bonnes
vacances en patron nicolas et
pimprenelle m'ont invité à aller passer
quelques jours avec eux en vacances
ce que je suis content
regardez le joli chapeau dont ils m'ont
fait cadeau pour que je n'attrape pas de
coup de soleil il est très joli hâle en
ours en route en route au revoir tous
nos petits et grands à me passer de
bonnes vacances pensez de bonnes
vacances
bonne nuit
[Musique]
e
[Applaudissements]
en
oh